Transcription: Virginia Elvira Gutiérrez Gallo
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
J'adore les mots.
Pourtant, j'ai jamais eu des facilités
pour mettre des mots sur mes émotions.
Alors maintenant,
à chaque nouvelle découverte,
je prends ça comme un nouvel outil
en ma possession.
L’autre jour, je lisais un bouquin
et je suis tombé sur cette expression :
prendre la tangente.
Et j’ai tout de suite su
que j’avais trouvé là un ensemble de mots
qui caractérisait très bien la direction
qu’avait prise ma vie entière.
Je m’appelle Jérémy Bigé et j’avais tout
pour faire un parfait ingénieur.
Un bac scientifique
avec plus de 18 de moyenne,
major de promotion
en classe préparatoire.
J'ai même des lunettes.
Et pourtant, j'ai choisi
de prendre la tangente.
Alors si vous êtes là ce soir,
j’imagine que…
vous n’avez pas fait
des maths votre passion?
Pas de soucis, on va repartir des bases.
Ça, c'est une courbe.
Ça va.
Et ça, en maths,
on appelle ça une tangente.
Imaginez maintenant que cette courbe
soit un chemin de vie tout tracé.
Un peu celui sur lequel on m’a mis
à la sortie de mon lycée
quand je me suis lancé
dans un cursus d’ingénieur.
Eh bien, le trait rouge
qui se barre à droite,
c’est la direction
que j’ai choisi de prendre.
Est-ce-que vous voyez
où je veux en venir ?
Prendre la tangente signifie s'esquiver.
Bifurquer. Sortir.
Changer de direction.
Et aujourd'hui, je n'ai plus rien à voir
avec le monde de l'ingénierie.
Aujourd’hui, je suis moniteur de ski,
accompagnateur en moyenne montagne
et sur mon temps libre, je me lance
dans de grandes aventures.
D’ailleurs, je rentre tout juste
d’une traversée de l’Asie centrale à pied
pendant trois mois sur 2 000 kilomètres.
Ce soir, je vais vous expliquer
ce qui me pousse
à sortir des sentiers battus
à l’encontre du regard des autres.
Il existe d’ailleurs un mot
dans le Larousse
pour définir le regard des autres
au sens où je l’entends :
le “qu’en dira-t-on”.
Il veut tout dire, n’est-ce pas ?
Autrement dit, j’ai tout pour répondre
aux critères sociaux initiaux
et pourtant, je pars
tracer ma propre route.
Que vont en penser les autres ?
Vont ils me juger ? Qu’en dira-t-on ?
Au lycée, je ne sais pas bien
ce que je veux faire de ma vie.
Je sais juste que je suis bon en maths.
Il y a une règle
presque implicite aujourd’hui :
quelqu’un qui est bon en maths,
bon en sciences,
mais qui ne sait pas bien
ce qu’il veut faire de sa vie,
il se retrouve en classe préparatoire.
C’est ce qui s’est passé,
ça n’a pas loupé.
Et puis deux ans plus tard,
en suivant la même logique,
en réalité, c’était plutôt
en suivant les autres,
je me suis retrouvé en école d’ingénieur
généraliste, à étudier les matériaux.
Mais ça m’allait super bien.
Ça m'allait très bien parce qu'en fait,
j'allais là où beaucoup vont.
Et bêtement, je me disais
que comme beaucoup y vont,
c’est forcément
que ça mène au bon endroit.
Les premières questions
sont arrivées plus tard.
Un an passe. Deux ans.
Et puis je vois qu’autour de moi
les autres étudiants
savent ce qu’ils veulent faire
après la remise des diplômes.
Moi, c’est toujours pas mon cas,
et ça me stresse de voir que les autres
ont une idée fixe et pas moi.
J'ai besoin d'avoir besoin
de plus de temps.
Mais en même temps, l'horloge tourne.
Un jour, j’assiste à une réunion
sur  les années de césure,
une césure, une suspension volontaire
des études.
Mais parfait !
Parfait pour repousser l'échéance,
pour gagner un peu de temps.
Reste juste à savoir comment remplir
cette année de césure.
Alors, j’ai dit que j’adorais les mots.
C’est pas mon unique passion.
Heureusement, j’adore marcher,
j’adore passer du temps en montagne.
C’est décidé, je pars traverser
l’Himalaya népalais à pied.
Direct. 1 500 kilomètres,
trois mois de marche,
accompagné par trois amis
rencontrés en classe préparatoire.
Ce défi sportif,
je le vois aussi comme un moyen
de susciter l’admiration chez les autres.
Il n'y a pas 36 000 personnes qui partent
traverser l'Himalaya népalais à pied.
Vous savez, en école d’ingénieur,
on nous apprend à cadrer les choses,
à travailler avec rigueur.
C’est exactement ce qu’on a fait.
Pendant un an, on travaille le projet,
on définit un timing,
on définit un itinéraire,
on sollicite des sponsors
pour qu’ils nous financent,
des médias pour qu’ils parlent de nous.
Seulement voilà, on se prend la définition
du terme “aventure” en pleine face.
Parce qu’une aventure désigne justement
tout ce qui peut arriver,
mais qui n’est pas prévisible.
Et à trop vouloir cadrer les choses,
ça nous a joué des tours.
Chaque jour, on se prend des obstacles,
des difficultés dans la figure.
Exemple : mon ami Aubin, ici,
traversé par une dysenterie
dans la région des Annapurnas,
qui perd dix kilos en huit jours.
Restait plus grand chose du bonhomme.
Et puis, d’obstacles en obstacles,
dedifficultés en difficultés,
on prend tellement de retard
qu’on n’atteint pas la frontière indienne,
l’objectif qu’on s’était fixé
dans le temps imparti par nos visas.
Premier échec.
Deuxième échec :
on est parti à quatre, on a fini à trois.
En cours de route, Thibaut décide
d'arrêter la traversée.
Il juge que la qualité des rencontres,
la qualité des paysages,
ne permettent pas de justifier
la difficulté physique et mentale
d’une telle marche, qui sont énormes.
Et cet arrêt de Thibault a fait germer
en moi une première prise de conscience.
Entre le moment où Thibault a émis
l’idée native d’arrêter la traversée
et le moment où il est réellement
passé à l’acte, s’est écoulé un mois.
Pourquoi ? Du fait des qu’en dira-t-on.
Que vont en penser les sponsors
qui nous financent ?
Que vont en penser les followers
qui nous suivent sur les médias ?
Qu’allons nous en penser, nous autres,
ses coéquipiers ?
Et s’il n’y avait eu personne pour juger
de la performance de Thibault ?
S’il n’y avait eu personne
pour regarder Thibault ?
Aurait-il autant souffert
dans cette prise de décision ?
La réponse, clairement c’est non,
parce qu’il aurait été bien plus
à l’écoute de ses envies,
de ses besoins profonds.
Alors on reprend la marche à trois
et on comprend très bien
que le timing va être trop serré.
Au début, pour moi, c’était inacceptable
de ne pas atteindre cette frontière
indienne parce que justement,
on avait crié haut et fort cet objectif.
Pourtant,
arrive le jour après 90 jours de marche
où nos visas expirent.
Je suis obligé d'accepter la situation.
Eh bien, croyez le, je l’ai fait
avec une profonde sérénité.
Comme si tout le chemin qui m’avait mené
jusque là, comme si toutes les foulées
qui m’avaient mené jusque là,
me suffisait amplement.
Comme si tout était en ordre en fait.
Alors je tire une première
leçon de cette aventure.
C’est que je n’ai de la satisfaction
non pas dans l’admiration
que je peux susciter chez les autres,
mais au regard de mon propre chemin.
À partir de ce moment-là,
dès que j’ai un peu de temps libre
en parallèle de mes études,
je repars marcher.
2020. Traversée des Pyrénées
par la haute route.
Je change drastiquement les choses
par rapport au Népal.
Je pars seul, sans timing, sans sponsors
et sans crier haut et fort mon projet.
Et en plus de ça,
je pars avec un sac de quatre kilos.
Et ces choix ont fait que j’ai marché
le cœur léger.
J’ai marché le cœur léger,
mais il y avait toujours cette petite voix
dans ma tête qui me répétait sans cesse :
« Il faut que tu fasses chaque jour
30 kilomètres a minima.
Il faut que tu arrives du plus vite
possible de l’autre côté des Pyrénées,
car quand même,
il faut que tu impressionnes. »
L’année suivante,
je pars  traverser les Balkans.
Les Balkans,
c’est cette région d’Europe de l’Est,
très méconnue, sujette aux préjugés.
Sur cette photo, je traverse
un champ de mines,
à cheval entre la Croatie et la Bosnie,
séquelle des guerres de Yougoslavie
de la fin du 20e siècle.
Je pars avec la même optique
que les Pyrénées, en changeant une chose.
Cette fois-ci, pas de destination,
pas de ligne d’arrivée si vous voulez,
et en supprimant la ligne d’arrivée,
c’est comme si j’avais supprimé
la possibilité de mesurer un défi sportif,
comme si j’avais supprimé
la possibilité de faire un record.
Et je me rends compte
qu’en baissant encore le cadre,
qu’en ne cherchant pas à
tout contrôler à tout prix,
c’est comme si j’abaissais
des barrières sur les côtés
pour laisser s’immiscer
des événements insoupçonnés.
Alors quand un paysan me siffle
depuis un champ
pour aller boire le rakia, alcool local,
que ce soit à 8 h du matin
quand j’ai encore le goût du dentifrice,
ou en plein milieu de l’après 12 h
en plein cagnard, j’accepte.
Et au terme de cette marche, en Albanie,
je me pose cette question :
et si c’était à refaire, mais que personne
ne me jugerait ou ne me regarderait,
est-ce que je ferais les choses
de la même façon ?
Et pour la première fois,
la réponse était oui.
C’est bien beau tout ça, mais arrive
le jour où je suis diplômé ingénieur.
Retour aux affaires, comme on dit.
Le jour des grands choix,
le jour tant redouté.
J’essaye de mettre en application
tout ce que j’ai appris jusque-là.
Je vois ça comme un obstacle
sur mon chemin.
Surtout ne pas me figer et réagir,
me poser les bonnes questions :
que veut mon cœur ?
Quelles sont les motivations
les plus profondes
qui gisent au fond de moi ?
Passer du temps dehors,
vivre sobrement, partager, transmettre.
Et là, ça a fait tilt.
Car j’avais compris que je pouvais
faire les choses pour moi
et non pas pour être valorisé
au regard de l’autre.
Alors mes épaules
ont perdu dix centimètres
et ça m’a enlevé beaucoup
de  pression dans mes choix de vie.
Aujourd’hui, je considère
que j’ai de la chance,
car j’ai toujours eu le choix.
En parallèle de mes études,
j’ai suivi une formation,
un diplôme d’état de ski alpin.
Alors pour beaucoup, moniteur de ski,
ça a beau vendre du rêve,
c’est dans la catégorie
des petits métiers.
Alors quand j’annonce autour de moi
que je laisse de côté l’ingénierie
pour partir sur un travail saisonnier,
voici ce qu’on a pu me dire :
« C’est dommage,
tu fais partie de l’élite,
mais tu vas finir moniteur de ski. »
Les qu’en dira-t-on, c’est dur.
Eh ben ça ne l’a pas été.
Parce que j’avais compris, à ce moment-là,
qu’accorder de l’importance
aux qu’en dira-t-on,
c’était ne pas accorder d’importance
à mes propres envies
et que je pouvais faire
les choses par sincérité.
Et faire les choses avec sincérité,
c’était donner du sens à une entreprise,
quelle que soit l’issue.
En 2022, donc cet été, je pars
faire ce que j’aime le plus.
Vous l’avez compris, marcher.
Traversée de l’Asie centrale.
2000 kilomètres seul
avec mon sac de cinq kilos.
Et encore une fois, j’essaye
de diminuer le cadre au maximum,
de ne pas tout contrôler.
C’est-à-dire que je reste dans l’accueil
de tout ce qui peut m’arriver,
que ce soit une bonne chose
ou une plus mauvaise.
Vous savez ce que c’est qu’un traquenard ?
Quand votre pote vous invite
pour boire un seul verre à 18 h,
et que vous finissez à 4 h du matin
en train de danser sur une table.
Les nomades d'Asie sont experts
dans l'art du traquenard.
Je me retrouve très régulièrement
sous la yourte.
Car il y a deux règles en Asie centrale :
première règle, on ne passe pas
devant une yourte sans y rentrer.
Deuxième règle,
on ne sort pas d’une yourte
sans être repu au lait de jument fermenté.
Le lait de jument fermenté,
c’est la boisson là qu’on voit
avec les trucs noirs qui flottent.
De ces expériences, j'ai appris à mettre
des mots sur mes envies profondes.
Et vous savez, je me pose la question
depuis très longtemps :
Quelle est la bonne voie pour moi ?
Je ne crois pas qu'il existe
une bonne voie.
Rien n'est linéaire.
Aujourd'hui, quand je regarde ma vie,
c'est un grand zigzag.
Pourtant, si c’était à refaire,
je referai les choses de la même façon.
Car j’ai compris que c’est
dans les détours, dans les obstacles,
face à ses failles, face à ses démons,
que l’on en arrive
à une version fidèle à soi-même.
Vous en connaissez beaucoup,
des moniteurs de ski
expert en ingénierie des matériaux ?
Ils ont de la chance les troisième étoile.
Plus sérieusement,
si vous devez retenir une chose,
c’est que vous avez le choix entre suivre
une direction influencée par les autres,
par la société, par les médias,
par la publicité, par influenceurs,
mais qui va mener à tout autre que vous.
Qui va entraîner beaucoup de pression,
beaucoup de frustration,
parce que vous allez chercher
à jouer un rôle qui n’est pas le vôtre.
Ou bien,
vous pouvez suivre une direction
non pas influencée par les autres,
mais inspirée.
Et l’inspiration consiste à piocher
chez l’autre le meilleur pour soi,
tout en laissant émerger
ses envies profondes,
et en coupant court
à la comparaison, à la tentation,
vous allez laisser sortir des envies
qui vous sont propres,
sur ce que vous voulez faire de votre vie
et non pas des envies
qui y sont inculquées par les autres.
Aujourd’hui, si j’arrive à mettre des mots
sur tout ça, c’est grâce à l’aventure.
Alors pour moi, c’était
une aventure sportive, pédestre,
mais c’est l’aventure
au sens général du terme,
qu’elle soit sportive, qu’elle soit
commerciale, artistique, entrepreneuriale.
L’important étant d’aller faire face
à ses failles,
d’aller faire des choses pour lesquelles
on ne se sent pas forcément à l’aise,
de partir à la recherche de soi.
Et c’est seulement en partant
à la recherche de soi
que vous arriverez
à mettre votre cœur à l’ouvrage.
Bonne route mes amis.